5 25 on your wednesday morning round two  of that road expansion blasting on fort  apache south of warm springs well it's  been delayed it was supposed to be  yesterday and in case you missed round  one here's how it went last friday  around noon  [Applause]  and one more time  [Applause]  so cool so when it's finished the  widening of fort apache is going to  reach down to huntington cove parkway  from warm springs about a half mile  north of wigwam whenever they do that  next round to blasting fort apache will  be closed with drivers detoured over to  durango as they say on tv stay tuned for  more information on this developing  story buckle up drive carefully please  put down that phone something driving  you crazy email me traffic 8  8newsnow.com